[Music]
Mike Myers announced he's expecting
another child and I was checking out the
local news local news found a really
unique way to tell the story Mike Meyer
says yeah baby Mike Meyer says yeah baby
Mike Meyer says yeah baby Mike Meyer
says yeah baby Mike Meyer says yeah baby
Mike Meyer says yeah baby
Mike - says yeah baby Mike Meyer says
yeah baby Mike Meyers says yeah baby
Mike Meyers says yeah baby Mike Meyers
says yeah baby
Mike Meyers says yeah baby Mike Meyers
says yeah baby Mike Meyers says yeah
baby Mike Meyers says yeah baby Mike
Meyer says yeah baby Mike Meyer says
yeah baby Mike Meyer says yeah baby Mike
Meyer says yeah baby Mike Meyer says
yeah baby
Mike Mike Meyer says yeah baby
Mike Meyer says yeah baby Mike Meyer
says yeah baby
Meyer said yeah baby Mike Meyer says
yeah baby Mike Meyer says yeah baby
Mike Meyer says yeah baby did I say that
right Jeff said right
[Applause]
get it a big country but somehow we're
all the same
is that what you take away from that
yeah